[Music]
hey you guys
it's monday yeah we're sitting here
watching poker roll around she's got
this damn mouse in her hand this [ __ ]
toy mouse she's got a claws in it just
one hand in it
she's got like a whole pile of over
there
she's like the only cat that knows how
to pick something up with her hand and
like carry it and she throws it throw it
yeah yeah she could if kitty baseball
was a thing she could be yeah she could
be a pitcher yeah a cat could throw
all right so i saw the great escape the
other day all-star cast i'd never seen
it it's a classic
it was pretty good
yeah you liked it yeah
it came out in
1963. i had actually seen it as a kid
but i hadn't uh seen it for [ __ ] man at
least like 20 something years
it's based on some [ __ ] that really
happened i mean it tells there's
disclaimer saying they kind of condensed
it condensed
characters down into you know several
characters into one person and they kind
of time compressed it
but it's about all these guys uh
allied troops that get they were in this
prisoner war camp
and uh it was there they kept escaping
and they had this huge escape attempt at
one time and they were trying to get 250
of them out uh they didn't get that many
out though uh i think that what was this
70 or 80 of them i think they got out
they got uh 75 or 76 out
of which spoiler alert this movie came
out in 1963 okay and it's based on a
book from 1950 so
uh
of that 50 of them got shot yeah they
machine gunned them uh and uh most of
them got brought back to the camp
although three did escape yeah uh just
like in the movie yeah
it's got everybody in it um
damn
uh
charles bronson's in it uh steve mcqueen
james james garner's in it richard
attenborough yeah uh donald please
donald please
a lot of british actors in it
and uh steve mcqueen does a bunch of
motorcycle stunts
except that world famous one that he
didn't do that one oh he didn't do the
jumping that was that was bud eakins
that was a very famous stunt guy who
actually he also did the driving and
bullet that guy but um steve mcqueen did
all the other ones except for that one
they would the uh the production company
wouldn't let him because of the
liability okay but he um he did all the
other stuff and he also put on a nazi
uniform and they shot him like chasing
himself
yeah
because like i guess the guys doing the
motors like they weren't as good as them
so yeah yeah yeah that's one thing about
mcqueen
uh he could ride motorcycles he can't
[ __ ] race cars he he was good that
kind of [ __ ] he you know he he was well
known in the lac
for uh
having really cool custom cars made for
themselves out of these custom shops
that they had around
around california southern california
time that he lived there back in the
days and he whatever car was out that
year
he had that
the best that he had the best car that
year and it went through those shops to
get it all modified and uh
some of steve mcqueen's personal
sports cars and hot rods are still
floating around in the car collector
scene you know they're you know they
know
what his cars are and they're worth a
lot of money
just all original
they're custom sports cars and hot rods
that steve mcqueen owned
but uh
yeah he was kind in certain ways kind of
like kind of like tom cruise in terms of
you know tom cruise connect he can fly
and you can shoot he can ride motorcycle
he was like that
um oh i think steve mcqueen was much
cooler yeah
i mean i'm just gonna say i don't think
anybody would be too surprised to hear
me say that only guy only guy missing
out of this movie would be uh lee marvin
lee marvin was another real james coburn
is in it though that's true doing a
really really
kind of regrettable australian accent
yeah yeah wait was he australian or for
or a kiwi was he from new zealand
yeah i think he was maybe from new
zealand i wish they would have just let
him talk the way i know that they were
trying to
make it more like the real thing which
was kind of like an international and
it's funny because they put steve
mcqueen in there
and
uh there was actually i think one
american in real life that was in on the
[ __ ] uh steve mcqueen character i think
was kind of like a a conglomeration of
three different dudes which they did say
in the disclaimer at the beginning that
some people had been you know kind of
mushed into one um weirdly
yeah it was almost all british people uh
there was one polish guy and then there
was an australian i think there was a
bunch of canadians and i don't think
they put any canadians in the movie was
james garner supposed to be canadian i
don't know because i thought the the
uniform that james garner was wearing
was not i thought maybe he was supposed
to be canadian but then he was doing the
fourth of july [ __ ] in the so maybe not
but it's weird that they didn't put any
canadians in the movie because they said
that like a bunch of them were actually
canadians the movie needed lee marvin
lee marvin was another real life badass
most of his [ __ ] unit got wiped out
and he personally got machine gun by the
japanese by the japanese yeah
he made it he was a marine i didn't
realize until i was researching this
movie that donald pleasence who plays
the forger in this
uh he in real life he was in the raf and
he did get shot down and he was in a pow
camp for a year yeah that was something
about this generation of actors you know
what i mean they had dudes
playing military and paramilitary roles
that had real [ __ ] military careers
they really were world war ii i think
james garner got shot down
i think most of them were thinking about
it
or he was wounded anyway hollywood was
good to get those guys in there because
they were credible
they were credible you know uh they
actually had certain skills and they
could pull off those roles because they
did that [ __ ] in real life
that was it was a good era
where eagles dare had a lot of that kind
of action in it yeah lee marvin was in
that too so was so was uh um charles
bronson a lot of people don't realize
how physically fit bronson was
he's in real good condition in this
movie and this is before his face got
real craggy craggly looking yeah he's
pretty young in this he's pretty i mean
fairly young
but they make sure to [ __ ] have a
scene where he takes his shirt off you
know i'm not sure if he was natural you
know testosterone was around during that
time
some early some early steroids were
around uh i i know he was on stuff later
on uh he because he just got leaner and
leaner and [ __ ]
muscles popping and [ __ ] you know like a
lot of people don't realize
how well built [ __ ] bronson was
especially for his time
he was in good shape
he plays the uh the tunnel king in this
one and it's interesting because he
plays a polish character
and uh
he does a good job he does actually um
he's lithuanian i think he yeah i think
he's i think he was born in the us but i
think he was his parents were immigrants
if i remember correctly um please
correct me if i'm wrong but um
yeah and it's interesting too because
he's in the his character in the movie
is claustrophobic
um you know and he's like that's why i'm
like the tunnel king because i gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here you know what i
mean and uh charles bronson is also
claustrophobic so they had like they had
a real thing going on like with the
character and everything so i thought
that was kind of neat so they had a lot
of the characters that
kind of did you know their own [ __ ] you
know and i mean they're kind of like uh
you know they did that kind of [ __ ] in
real life um camp guy said or actually
fourth throwdown said this movie was on
tv all the time when i was a kid and i
used to love it i've watched it in adult
sense and i find it to be rather sad now
it's interesting but it is very sad like
i said if you haven't seen it uh pretty
much everybody dies
but um
you know it's the escape like three of
the people escape but most of them don't
make it yeah what's kind of sad about
this movie is uh these dudes are taking
duty pretty [ __ ] pretty seriously i
mean it starts off in the beginning the
german commandant of the camp basically
says like list this just behave
stay here and we'll just wait out we'll
sit the war out yeah all right you find
out that the comma dot he's not a nazi
all right he doesn't really like hitler
but he just got to keep his mouth shut
about it
and really
that was the right call
they should have just sat the war out
because it was going to be over in a
couple years anyway they just their
escape their escape did not [ __ ]
contribute to the war effort matter of
fact it just got 50 dudes killed
it would have been better than they just
said there
and then
you wouldn't have had a movie
yeah but i mean it really did happen in
real life but it was a thing of honor
and that's what they were they were
ordered to do that kind of stuff so yeah
and i think that
chain of command right well no you know
what i don't know if that i think that
was just like a movie conceit uh that
they said you know the one of their
things is they're supposed to like [ __ ]
with this was supposed to escape so they
could [ __ ] with the germans and stuff i
don't think that was like any kind of
real
thing that they were supposed to be
doing um i think they just did that for
the movie but honestly i think the whole
no i remember they were kind of it was
their duty to escape maybe just the
british i don't know if the americans
but i do seem to remember that i have to
go back into the military rolodex of
what
of what what your standing orders were
during that time i know what the rules
of engagement were
and basically you know how they
conducted missions and i think it kind
of was their military duty to attempt to
attempt to escape and to harass
which that falls in line with the
thinking of the time
but i have to go back and check you
might be right but i don't know i think
so i think that i think that's right
yeah i don't know i'm just saying what i
read on wikipedia so i'm so i'm actually
not sure but um but yeah so it would
have varied country to country yeah
that's what i'm saying and and because
this was in real life and in the movie
it was kind of like a bunch of different
because what ends up happening if you
didn't if you've never seen this movie
uh it's based on a true story ish you
know what i mean it's fairly accurate
but they did take a lot of liberties
uh it's a bunch of
officers they're all officers right yeah
um from you know the different allied uh
countries
and they are all put into this new
german pow camp which is in
poland and
this camp was specifically made
for officers who had tried to escape
from other camps before so it was like a
high security for the time
so they're going to put them all in one
place so they can watch them
and like you said it's interesting too
because another thing that i was uh that
i was reading about when i was kind of
researching like the real story behind
this was that
another thing that they kind of left out
of the movie was they said a lot of the
stuff that you see them do in the movie
like doing like the um the uniforms and
like the papers and everything they said
that that was actually fairly easy for
them because a lot of the german guards
like you said didn't really like the
nazis so they were just kind of like
okay we'll help you so a lot of the
german guards helped the help the
escapees as well like in forging papers
and helping them with the uniforms when
they got out and all this other kind of
stuff so it wasn't but i you know the
thing about it though is i think like
the whole kind of theme of the movie
movie was not so much because i think
like at the very end when james garner
and some of the other ones that got
captured get brought back to the camp
and he's sitting there saying you know
was it worth it you know 50 dudes got
killed and you know they just [ __ ]
shot him in the head or whatever and the
other guy's kind of like well that
depends on how you look at it i mean you
did kind of like [ __ ] with the germans
you did you know cause them to
have to use up resources like chasing
your asses so you know maybe it was
successful and like i said i kind of
feel like the whole point of the movie
was that you couldn't like uh you know
they had like indomitable spirit you
know what i mean you couldn't like it
was the principle of the thing they just
that's what more right they just didn't
want to be you know they just didn't
want to be locked up it didn't matter to
them yeah like they didn't just want to
kind of sit there like you said it was
like an honor
thing where it's just right and so
that's i think they did a really good
job like conveying that dudes in that
generation had a lot of [ __ ] swag and
they were military and you put them all
in a damn prison camp together they're
gonna motivate one another talking a lot
of [ __ ] stunting
putting you stunting and [ __ ] you
know
trying to impress the guys around them
about how how much that they're [ __ ]
giving giving the enemy a hard time
and so and uh
they would have [ __ ] hated to just
sit around idle so they wanted to be in
a war effort so let's try to escape
that's what you're talking about
uh where they ordered to do it maybe
but i don't know
it was probably just based on yeah
you're supposed to do it but it doesn't
really behoove you to do it like there's
no punishment if you don't do it
yeah yeah because this i mean it was a
pow camp so it wasn't a walk in the
[ __ ] park or anything because they
did actually have one guy that tried to
he that kind of flipped out and tried to
like just go through the fence and they
shot him oh yeah which that would happen
anywhere which yeah that that that
really did happen but you know uh
compared to
what you might be picturing
it wasn't really that i mean the
officers they let them kind of like walk
around in the daytime they had fish yeah
they had their own rooms well they had
like rooms like roommates they had like
two or three
guys in a row that was a cushy living
situation for for for military yeah you
know what i mean the infantry was out
sleeping on the ground in the snow yeah
i mean the officers they had a i mean
they had a lot of freedom yeah you know
this [ __ ] they were like making
moonshine and commandant was right just
let's just sit here and wait out the war
it's going to be over soon yeah and that
really was the smart thing to do just
they were [ __ ] hacked to ass acted a
fool
and uh
wanted to uh to see some action and they
wanted to escape they did because they
want to they didn't have to
and most of them that's why they were
all in this one camp because all of them
had tried to escape yeah they had they
wanted to put them all in one place so
they could keep an eye on them because
they had tried to escape from every
other camp that they'd been in because
most of them had been shot down at
various times and places personally i
wouldn't have done it
i would have done it no but they just
couldn't [ __ ] stand it they couldn't
stand it it would have been better just
to sit out there and wait out the war
they only had a couple years left
at this point maybe i mean
you had to have known though that they
couldn't hold out forever i mean i
didn't remember i hadn't seen this movie
for such a long time i didn't remember
that initially steve
mcqueen uh he comes in there and he's
they call him the cooler king because
he's always like causing trouble so they
always put him in like solitary [ __ ] him
in the hole yeah
and and he just like not bothered by it
at all he's like yep here i go bye so he
initially him and ives the scottish dude
that flips out and gets shot later on um
they have their own escape [ __ ] going on
but then they have um roger what's his
name roger bartlett that's like based on
a real guy the guy that richard
attenborough plays he's called big x
and he's kind of like he was brought
over by the gestapo
and he's like
that was based on a real guy that wasn't
like an amalgamation
and so he's escaped from a bunch of
places so he's like a big troublemaker
and honestly i love that like the second
he comes into the camp like everybody
knows who he is and they're like guess
who's here holy [ __ ] so then it's like
all of them are just kind of and he just
comes in and he's like okay you're gonna
forage and you're gonna do this and
you're gonna dig a tunnel and we're
gonna do this and they just like work it
all out and everybody's just like yes
sir and they just all do their their
regular [ __ ] like one guy starts [ __ ]
taking old coats and stuff and sewing
them into you know civilian clothes or
different uniforms and stuff you know
donald pleasant starts like forging all
the papers to get out it's like they
start just making this really elaborate
plan and they even have the thing where
they dig
three tunnels tom dick and harry yeah
and uh you know they hide them under the
[ __ ] boiler thing or whatever and
they have the tile under there and
because they're kind of like well if one
of them gets found then we'll have like
a couple other backups one thing that
they didn't mention in the movie that
actually did happen in real life was
that at this particular camp the germans
actually had seismographs so if you were
digging or doing any [ __ ] around there
they'd be like hey what's that but
you know but it is true that seven i
think it was 76 of them got out yeah but
50 of them got shot and then like a
bunch of them got brought back and then
but three of them did escape so in the
movie who gets james coburn gets away uh
french resistance
charles bronson's character gets away
him and his friend they both get away
they just show them getting on a boat
and they [ __ ] off but everybody else
either gets shot or gets brought back to
the camp again tactically
or strategically i don't think it was a
a good trade 50 guys got killed three or
four of them made it up made it out and
escaped and then the germans really
didn't suffer any perceivable permanent
losses
i think
and i think one of the things when
you're watching the movie i don't think
it was really kind of uh
i don't think they really uh
discussed it in detail it seemed like
the inmates or the prisoners
were gamifying the
uh the escape it was just a way of
keeping the germans constantly on their
toes and trying yeah that that's really
what it was because they would do little
escapes and then turn themselves back in
yeah uh they would pretend to cut wire
but not really cut it and they would cut
they would get into a truck and try to
sneak out underneath bales of hay
full well knowing that there's no way to
do it there's no way to get out so they
were just they were constantly [ __ ]
with the germans yeah they were just
doing it to be a pain in the ass on
purpose to keep them working which i can
understand that yeah
that's
exactly what they were doing i would do
that they were constantly trying to just
test the boundaries
like uh you know the rules were that if
if you stepped across this line right
here the guys in the towers would
machine gun you but what if you dropped
a ball just on the line and walked up to
it you know just constantly [ __ ] with
them yeah you know
that part i understand
but the whole thing that let's this all
of us escape because hey mayhem the
germans didn't tolerate that [ __ ] the
one a lot of the ones those 50 of them
that they caught they just machine
gunned them
make sure they didn't try it again yeah
and we would have done the same to the
germans if they'd escaped our which they
did we were bringing them here and some
of them did escape and i think we did
kill some of them
but uh
a lot of them uh a lot of their stories
about people people don't realize that
the [ __ ] we had german prisoner war
camps here in the united states down the
south
and weird [ __ ] would happen like uh some
of them would escape and then people
didn't care that they escaped and then
it ended up like marrying an american
girl
just that kind of [ __ ] was weird too but
that happened
then he'd come back
because they couldn't run anywhere
america's too big
there's and you know but just a couple
guys walking around couldn't
cause any
sabotage to the american war machine not
not on foot in the deep south i think it
was louisiana's where the camp where one
of the camp was that i was thinking
about
but evidently they would they would let
them go too they just let them go like
you know okay i go to town
because where are they going to go they
were right you know
and [ __ ] you know they give them
money and they were making money and
selling stuff and trading and
hanging out in a tavern and to come back
to prison
that would be weird too when you think
about it that's pretty funny but it
makes a lot of sense when you they're
not really trying to escape
and they're not hostile
yeah because the germans actually
weren't hostile once they were here
fourth row down makes a good point i
feel like the germans probably tolerated
these escape attempts to some degree
because it gave the pows something to do
yeah otherwise they might have had a
riot on their hands yeah pretty much uh
but yeah i do kind of feel like and the
interesting thing too about this movie
one thing i had forgotten that it was
almost three hours long although it
doesn't seem like it because it's pretty
i mean it moves along at a pretty good
clip like it's an adventure you know
what i mean um because there is a
significant amount of time like after
they get out and then you know they're
all kind of going off like steve
mcqueen's going off on his motorcycle
and
you know uh some of them are trying to
like james garner and donald pleasant
like steal a plane and they're trying to
like fly to switzerland and all this
other kind of stuff and uh so they're
kind of all you know and then some and
then big x and the other guy are trying
to like get on a train
and
they i
one of my favorite scenes is that which
is but it's sad but it's like when they
get caught because remember they were
like rehearsing like because they were
speaking german and then they were like
now and then they asked him a question
in english and he answered in english
and he was just like you can't do that
but that's exactly how he got caught
like he was getting on the bus and he
was about ready to go and then like the
other guy says good luck and he's like
thanks and he was like [ __ ]
it up to answer the question no um
um
what was it
hogan's uh [ __ ] dirty dozen did not
inspire hogan's heroes this movie
probably inspired hogan's heroes yeah i
think they did dirty dozen is a totally
different
story
you know it has lee marvin in it yeah
you know another movie that this
inspired chicken run
the animated it's stop motion animation
it's the same uh the same studio that
did uh the wallace and grommet shorts uh
they did and it's actually really cute i
saw it in the theater and it's a chicken
run but it's like the great escape but
it's chickens trying to get out of this
farm so they don't get killed like for
meat and it's just it's super super
funny it even has like one of the
chickens like bouncing a baseball
against the wall of the cell
like steve mcqueen but one of the things
that's cool about this movie and i think
and i actually can't believe that they
pulled it off
is that
this movie it's it's tragic pretty much
i mean like i said spoiler alert they
pretty much all get killed or they get
recaptured right
um you know
they wanted to get 250 dudes out but the
germans like caught them like you know
they found a tunnel but they found the
tunnel like after only 76 people had
gotten out
and then they found most of those people
and so
but it's so it's really sad but it's
still
like the beginning part of it it's
almost kind of like it has like funny
bits in it like it's almost kind of like
funny and like entertaining it's not
like a comedy but there is a lot of
levity in it
and so it's i think it did a really good
job in balancing the sort of like
comedic
funny stuff and it's just it's crazy to
think but i guess hogan's heroes is kind
of the same vibe where it's just kind of
like how do you make something funny
about a [ __ ]
nazi prisoner of war war camp but they
did it they weren't being tortured right
they weren't it wasn't inhumane
conditions there's a lot better
conditions than the soldier in the field
sleeping outside so
they were bored and they were having fun
with the germans let's try to escape
yeah yeah that's i mean you could tell
that they were actually having a really
good time like they you know they're
having all their secret meetings and
it's just kind of like they all had
their [ __ ] jobs to do and you know
they were just solving problems like you
said they were keeping themselves busy
the camp was being run by the luftwaffe
that was the [ __ ] air force all right
you're not talking about a
a concentration camp like out in
auschwitz that was yeah run by ss and
that wasn't happening inside the borders
of germany that was a secret program
most germans didn't know about it you
know
and uh they talked about it in
euphemisms they were evacuating the
jewish people to safety so get on these
trains we're gonna evacuate
everything is just how you describe it
you always gotta all the camouflaged
[ __ ] wording you know that's why they
got on there okay yeah we're we're
they're gonna take care of us they're
helping us they're getting us out of the
war zone you know
no
no they're [ __ ] erasing you well they
pulled that [ __ ] on some of the
characters in here too where they put
them in the truck and they're like yeah
we're driving you back to the camp oh
never mind we just stopped in this field
yeah [ __ ] stretch your legs machine
we got hours before we're gonna get
there they gotta stretch their legs they
[ __ ] machine gun
and that was i think that was the
gestapo did that no it wasn't the
gestapo gestapo got the other guy yeah
because they were after they were after
big x specifically because he was like
kind of the head
one and like i said that was based on a
real dude that was uh you know that was
masterminded like a lot of different
escapes from various people who don't
know the difference between the the
german army the
the vermont the difference between the
vermont the [ __ ] luther the
kriegsmarine
big difference between those guys and
waffen ss and then there's three
different kinds of ss ss police that
says security waffen ss and then they
had
gestapo gestapo was not military
gestapo was not even a proper term that
was that was kind of like a slang term
it just meant that was just their secret
police
they were plain clothes policemen they
were taken from like they were pr
investigators usually criminal
investigators that's
where the that was their background
they just were working for the
um
german for for for the
the german national socialist party to
root out domestic enemies and foreign
enemies they were spy hunters and
uh to anti-terrorism uh anti-terrorist
type units you know they all use
familiar language to describe what
they're doing anti-partisan activities
which means anti-terrorism
um
it
the u.s has the same kind of units they
just the application is just a little
bit different supposedly but all these
things can be turned in on people they
think are domestic enemies the next
thing you know you're looking just like
that system all right you got to be
careful with this kind of [ __ ] man
you're wrong
whenever regimes come into power they
inherit all these institutions and they
can get them to do what they want to do
you know and then germany was the same
way
but you didn't want to fall in the hands
of
those secret police guys they were kind
of like the fbi i guess you could say
renown for [ __ ] torture and during
their interrogations you know beat you
up fists
drug you
oh take pliers and to you and
damn starvation and
[ __ ] burn you you know they were bad
real bad pull fingernails out
and they were done with you [ __ ] they
just hand you over to them
ss security
and they can send you the concentration
cap
you know that that was it for you
but that's
so some of these guys that escaped they
were in the hands of all these different
agencies it was different every time i
think it was the ss that machined those
guys
well it might have been because they
picked up like a whole bunch of ones
like i said the real troublemaker ones i
think that camp was that was mostly
luftwaffe yes yeah lucifer was running
the camp yeah so they weren't
yeah yeah and captain blair says usually
pilots or high up officers were treated
well on both sides yeah yeah in this
particular camp and like i said um you
know it's dramatized for the movie but
this camp was i mean the prisoners they
couldn't leave obviously or they would
get shot but
they had a lot of freedom to just walk
around during the day um
you know honestly they it was easy for
them to plan an escape because
they you know they would let them have
like drawing classes and they just
right
so and they didn't have guards watching
them all the time
um you know and they were smuggling
stuff in it's funny because james
garner's character who's he was the
scrounger that's his job they said when
he was in the military that was what he
that was what he did so again that was
like real life
here it wouldn't even be considered
maximum security would have been like
medium security yeah
yeah because like i said they you know
they were making moonshine yeah uh at
one point and like i said they had this
big impromptu fourth of july celebration
like the americans and they you know had
the flag and they were going around the
drum like playing yankee doodle danny
and stuff like that and uh you know
doing like fireworks like blowing [ __ ]
up in the in the garbage can or whatever
and they were like gardening and it's
funny because um you know the whole
thing where they put those like socks
full of dirt like in the pants and they
were you know uh spilling it out in the
in the gardening
yard or whatever um pretty sure
they used that for in uh shawshank
redemption in the movie i don't remember
if it was in the story but it was for
sure in the movie that's where they got
the idea and that there was that one
british guy he had had he had already
been handed over to the luther because
the gestapo had him yeah and they were
interrogating him
and he wouldn't give up any information
they suspected he had some information
on something remember what it was they
thought he was a spy yeah some sort
but they couldn't get anything out of
him and that so when you first see him
he rolls into camp the the the the
secret police are handing him over but
then later on they once he escapes they
make
the gestapo makes it a priority get that
particular guy they do find him
eventually
yeah because that was the main guy they
you know he as like i said i think the
gestapo brought that brought yeah at the
beginning and that's kind of like what
was a big deal because everybody said oh
he's the one that engineered all those
other escapes so he was kind of like
really known for it
yeah he was like the leader so when he
got there like they all immediately like
started planning like the next escape
because that's just what they did like
every time they were in a camp that's
the first thing they would do is try to
get the [ __ ] out and like i said steve
mcqueen he even like tried to escape he
didn't really initially want to be in
with that group it was a bunch of dudes
like i said they all had jobs but steve
mcqueen was just kind of like now i got
my own escape [ __ ] going on he was just
gonna tunnel under the fence
and he got caught like him in ives it
was just him it was just two guys and
he's like i don't want to do that whole
like big group thing it's like more
likely that you'll get caught but he
tried did try to tunnel under and he got
caught so he got put in solitary for
like 20 days or something like that and
then when he got out
um
the group was trying to get him to
go under the fence again
and then go and like do reconnaissance
because they needed to know like where
the nearest town was where the train
station was all this other kind of stuff
and so they wanted him to go out and do
reconnaissance and then turn himself
back in
and he didn't want to do it at first but
then after a while he like succumbed so
he was just kind of like okay i'll do it
so he like pretty much did exactly that
so he was the guy that like got all the
information
he's talking how the germans treated
prisoners of war pretty well yeah
there's some caveats to that
not russians especially not russian
women usually russian female women were
shot on the spot or hung
the the
german generals and german fighting
units
thought that
armed female soldiers were just an
abomination uh they they weren't even
considered they were considered them
terrorists they just killed them
uh they wouldn't take them and then if
they did take uh any russians prisoner
they ended up in concentration camps and
killed for being communists
so you know if you're they hated
russian communists or any kind of
bolshevik they just thought they were
just a weaponized human being
just with bad and improper thoughts and
uh you gotta go
so uh no
usually like the life expectancy on a
russian prisoner was [ __ ] a couple
months
they they'd starve them
and evidently there's reports where
they'd have a prisoner war camp with
americans in one side of it and on the
other side of the fence they'd have the
russians
butted right up next to them they'd be
feeding the americans but not feeding
the russians you'd see the russians just
wither away over by they'd be working
them to death not feeding them they were
real low on the feeding priority now
during a lot of that time you know it
was towards the end of the war russia
barely had any excuse me germany could
barely feed its own population it was
just bomb to [ __ ]
it was bombed to [ __ ] it looked like the
surface of the moon
there was no real food production they
were just on bare minimum rations
and the only reason why they were
feeding the british and the americans is
because the the higher ups knew that the
war was gonna be lost and they were
gonna they were gonna try to allied
themselves with the american and the
western side to help protect themselves
from the russians which is actually what
happened that's exactly what happened so
they didn't want to make england and
america mad so they fed those guys
they they couldn't afford to feed
germans or excuse me russians
you know what's kind of hilarious is
that this movie for whatever reason
um i don't know about nowadays but they
would always show it every christmas
around in the uk yeah like it was kind
of like it was one of those movies it
was like their version of die hard i
guess
i mean there's like really nothing i
guess there's a couple times when uh the
one guys like has the choir like singing
christmas songs while because they're
trying to drown out the noise of them
like digging the tunnel and stuff and
they do sing a couple christmas carols
but it doesn't seem like it's taking
place at christmas time i don't know
they really they don't really say
anything about it but i just thought
that was kind of funny it's just one of
those movies that
people associate in the uk or they used
to like with christmas because they
always showed it that was like one of
their big special christmas movies that
they would show and it's just kind of
like and it was funny because earlier i
had remembered that uh eddie izzard did
uh did a bit about the great escape and
uh on on uh dressed to kill one of his
older
shows and uh so i was watching that
again earlier and i remember how [ __ ]
funny that was and and how was saying
that steve mcqueen was like the american
put in the movie like just to make it
sell because nobody wanted to watch a
bunch of british actors
but it's just kind of like oh you put
all these british actors in the movies
and they're just kind of like well no
american's to want to watch that so
let's go there's somebody in there there
was something too well yeah that's
that's why that was that's why it was a
joke you wanted cross market sales
appeal
and then uh then taco turner in there
too though was he canadian no no he was
american james garner was in it he was
an american i can't i don't know i don't
remember if he was actually if he was an
american or a canadian i can't remember
i mean he's no i know i know but i'm i
think he is yeah but sometimes that
sometimes that throws me because
sometimes an actor that i always thought
was an american internship canadian
um you know but but yeah where uh the
whole thing about steve mcqueen like
escaping and it's like it's like he
didn't even have a uniform or anything
it's just he escapes like wearing a
jeans and a t-shirt disguised as an
american man
and he just looked at a [ __ ] he
didn't even bother like it he's too cool
for like a uniform but what's funny
about the motorcycle scenes is that he's
supposedly stole that motorcycle off a
german soldier but it's obviously to me
a triumph bonneville dressed up to look
like a bmw german motorcycle but it's
obviously a bonneville it is it's
actually it's i think it says try and
trap tiger or try something where did
i swear to god i saw it
it looked like a split single it's on
the it wasn't it wasn't a bonneville i
don't think okay but i can't remember
it's a triumph motorcycle
uh it might have been that yeah i can't
see it's this like [ __ ]
notes are so long
that i can't like find it now but yeah
it is a triumph i do remember that but i
can't remember like what the other with
the rest of i thought that was him
ramping it over that barbed wire fence
that was a good job and i know that he
can do that well bud eakins was a friend
of his and and kind of looked like him
okay um
like i said steve mcqueen did all the
other stunts but that one famous jump
which you know still considered one of
the best stunts in movie history uh was
bud eakins like i said budd eakins was
the same guy that he's kind of legendary
like among stunt people and he also did
most of the driving and bullets you see
him do some [ __ ] that if you ride you
know it's kind of hard i mean he's
on pavement
rock hard knobby tires of those days and
he locks both both wheels up comes to a
[ __ ]
halt in the road
and does kind of a 180 on in in the skid
on his brakes and basically does a 180
in the in the road
and then accelerates out of it
in kind of like a hairpin type turn
in order to evade
two motorcycles that were behind him and
you see that mode him slide that
motorcycle across there and you know
those were not lightweight motorcycles
they were not little they were not meant
for agility
they were
kind of just long heavy ungainly
motorcycles by the day standards with
weak brakes
and not much power and no real
suspension
i mean you had springs and a little bit
of oil maybe in a telescopic front end
but
it's bounce all over the way and pogo
and [ __ ] you know but he was he was
riding it fast across
across the open fields
catching air
well not easy yeah i mean well yeah i
mean that's why that's you know that
whole sequence is so beloved yeah
because of that like anybody that knows
anything about motorcycles you get on a
modern dirt bike that's nothing but he's
not on a dirt bike he's on yeah he's on
basically what would be like a harley
sportster stretch sportster similar to
that it's just not much modern there's
that's not a modern motorcycle
hard to ride under those conditions
at that speed fourth jordan said yeah
he's gonna travel across germany
disguised as a 60s hipster
yeah good luck but uh yeah he did get
caught well he didn't he didn't get
killed though he gets brought back to
the camp though well didn't he steal
that guy's uniform
uh he stole that at one point he did but
it that was like pretty late german
that was pretty late in the escape
attempt because he gets tangled up in
the barbed wire that's how he gets
caught like the motorcycle kind of
crashes and laughs about it yeah and
he's just like well you got me yeah and
then they just take him back to the camp
and then he just immediately gets put
back in solitary yeah and starts
throwing the baseball again so you know
that he's
plotting another one because like i said
i kind of feel like that's
you know yeah in hindsight maybe it was
dumb they could have just like sat there
and those 50 guys would still be alive
but
that's kind of not the point of the
movie though i mean the point of the
movie was
they're just going to like keep escaping
man they just can't help it you said a
big triumph back then maybe about 750 uh
maybe less probably more like 6.50
i think i think the triumphs of that day
might have been about 650.
there's not much power there
but you know
i guess you could say decent torque
i mean once you got that motor kind of
spooled up and once it was rolling
you could get a little bit of speed out
of it
uh you'd be maxing out the suspension
though you know and there's like i said
it's drum brakes
you get maybe one or two decent good
stops out of a drum brake before it
healed before it heats up and up to
where it's just it's just more like
slowing down than stopping you know
but
if you get used to a bike's weaknesses
and its capabilities you can kind of
adapt your riding style to
work within those parameters and he's
that's what he's doing
you know he they didn't know any better
back then you had to have a lot of balls
you know if i were got on that thing i'd
be very uncomfortable it would take me a
long time before i trusted myself on it
yeah because those they're just
they're not made to be ridden quickly
um not safely
and especially not over
open ground
and the tire compounds of the day were
just shitty you know
the knobbies were real rock hard and
no traction on asphalt you know easy to
slip and slide around
that's just pogoing suspensions and
a lot of weight
usually uh kind of weight in the wrong
areas so
not a lot of not a lot of stability you
know
did i mention that jon stur just
directed this there's the same guy that
did uh riley no different guy he also
directed magnificent seven oh uh ice
station zebra he did a bunch of other
ones like that action flakes uh
interestingly one thing i didn't notice
until i was watching kind of like a a
cinema breakdown of this was that there
are no uh close-ups please correct me if
i'm wrong that he wanted to show
kind of like a you know the camaraderie
of like all the guys so he's like
usually there's a bunch of the prisoners
are framed in one shot they never like
do close-ups really on any one person
because they wanted it to be like an
ensemble which i thought was kind of
interesting yeah i just saw this this
was on the wikipedia page what i was
going back to what i was saying before
about christmas movies it says in a 2006
poll in the united kingdom regarding the
family film that television viewers
would most want to see on christmas day
the great escape came in third and was
first among the choices of male viewers
so there you go for whatever reason this
is a christmas movie at the end okay i
don't know why
well no i kind of feel like um
because i know so i know there's some
some of y'all are
are brits did wasn't like it always uh
didn't they always show like james bond
movies around christmas as well because
it was just i mean before
streaming and before all that kind of
stuff when it was like a big deal like
it was an event you know what i mean
like this the big movie that was uh that
was on tv on christmas i kind of feel
like a lot of times it was james bond
movies too
if i'm remembering correctly i'm not but
yeah uh but yeah this is a [ __ ]
classic if you haven't seen it um
you know it's funny that it's considered
a family film because like i said it is
kind of a bummer but it's still like
it's it's pretty like entertaining and
still has like funny stuff in it even
though it's really kind of tragic they
pretty much all get killed
but
patriotic
yeah well yeah like i said it's kind of
like well it shows like a bunch of dudes
from like different countries and
they're all like working together as a
team
just toward a common goal
and
they're just there to [ __ ] with the
germans and it's like if they get killed
they're like well that sucks but you
know our whole mission in life is to
[ __ ] with them and get the hell out of
here so that's what we're gonna do and
they just keep doing it
um you know so like i said the the
indomitable human spirit that's kind of
like what the theme of it is they like
they won't allow themselves to be ground
down i guess like they still have
optimism
so you know so i guess that's kind of
like that that's a nice message even
though it's got a sad ending but yeah so
uh this is actually on amazon prime for
free at the moment uh if you haven't
seen it you want to watch it then uh i
would definitely recommend checking it
out and i guess that'll we'll wrap it up
for today we're tomorrow we will be
talking about
alien versus predator because that's
what we watched last night
avp the first one yeah it's well we
first we started watching we saw the
director's cut was yeah well it was the
unrated although i'm not really sure why
it had to be unreal because the
difference between that one i couldn't
tell the difference either but yeah
we'll we'll talk about that tomorrow
like afternoon but yeah that's what
we're gonna do tomorrow so uh yeah we're
gonna do requiem also eventually yeah
yeah i mean
all right yeah well we can watch that
yeah whenever i mean we can't watch it
tonight because we're going out but you
know what i mean all right so uh thanks
everybody for dropping by thanks for
super chats and we will see you guys
again tomorrow
bye